So to compute the number of steps, what we're going to do is start at the top
and count how many steps it gets from the top to the bottom.
So here's the first step. It has 8 operations.
Second step, third step, fourth step, fifth step, sixth step,
and then we've computed the final results.
So we'd say there are 6 steps here.
What's the total amount of work?
Well, to do that, we count the number of operations.
That's 8 + 4 + 4 + 2 + 2 + 1.
That gives us 21 operations to compute the final answer here.
When we discuss algorithms, we'll often discuss these metrics
not so much in terms of numbers--the number of steps or the total amount of work--
but instead as functions of the size of the input.
So we might have a totally different problem,
and we might say that the amount of work in that problem
is proportional to the size of the input squared
or the number of steps in this particular problem is proportional to the size of the input.